AISION C
SEEM TO ONLY BTO ADAM
KI
THE RECENTLS
IVED,
INCLUDING ONE THATTENED WIFE ANN
WE WILL NOT BE THE
YOU CAN FIND I.
YOU HEAR
SOMEF LE VITRIOL THAT THESE MEME
SIMPLY FOR SG UP T GIVE A WARNI
WHAT YOU'RE AB HEAR IS
EXTRAORDINARILY GRAPC ANVE
AN'T SAY A
HA
QUICKLY A
B A, YOU PIECOF
KNOW YOU'R[ ] --
T YOU, COMING TO
YOUR HOUSETTLE
[
>> THIS OFOURSE, NOT ADAM INREC
AT HIS HOME HIM AND HITHE SAME
E INSURRECTION AREO IN
MANY INSTANCES FUE TNGEROUS A WA
ON THESE-WG PLATFORMS
E  LIZ  ECUTRP'CIENEY W
G
GUILAITHAT'S WHERE WE.
IF THERE IS ANY DOUBT THAT A
RMS.
THREATAGMEMBERS OF
CONGRESS A U ID  10,00CASES LASA
THIS PRONG GVEKE THIS.IS GMEBOD
KILLED.
E THAT IS
GEG LE OBE
OF OF PE